when I was in Egypt on the walls from
the hieroglyphics showed basically what
they were saying was childbirth and how
women would kind of sit and like gravity
would the baby would squat out yeah and
it would be a far more you know natural
process even like when you go to other
countries and the toilet is in the
ground squat like it's you know and here
in America we have a you know squatty
potty potty let's put our feet up and
yeah so it's kind of ergonomically
correct and they said that it was
man that wanted to watch this and be
part of it and see this that women were
then laid down so that the man could
sort of like watch the process happen
and be there or see it in a way that
they like to see it yeah um that that
things were changed is there any truth
to that is there any truth the way a
baby's born has best put into it like
just twisted and flipped and turned and
laid on a bed the wrong way yeah so it
we need to look back a couple hundred
years prior to even talking about women
laying flat to give birth
so throughout all of time birth was
attended by midwives men weren't allowed
there's a wonderful book called The Red
Tent that described the experience of
how women would Gather in these red
tents and you know they would menstrate
together and it was all of their sisters
and their aunties and their grandmothers
and they would share these experiences
together and you bet your ass when they
were in labor they would go back and be
surrounded by these women and of course
there was women that had more knowledge
of birth and they were probably out
collecting the different herbs in the
field uh that they knew would assist
with you know the mom having an easy
birth and you know I want you to imagine
how elephants give birth I don't know if
you've ever seen it before but they
circle around the elephant and they sway
side to side because it's this Natural
Energy right when you're holding a baby
what's the first thing you naturally do
you just start this natural sway
and so that's how it's been throughout
all of time we've always been surrounded
and these these Circles of women and uh
you know there there's that that natural
vibrational energy that moves through
everybody in the room that creates a
safe Sacred Space when we look back
throughout time about when that started
to change there was a book that was
written um in the Catholic church in
1484 and it basically translated to the
witch's hammer and so they they brought
this throughout Europe and they
basically were saying
um at that time that the greatest threat
to the church was midwives okay so this
is when the witch trials began and
everybody always thinks of like the
Salem witch trials and that's like
really the only thing that Hollywood has
given us for the history and I call it
the her story it's really not history
it's about her at that time there was
over nine million women that were killed
um with with the witch trial and so I
want you to think about this so in
Germany alone there was a hundred
thousand women that were murdered and
not just like midwives like it was
literally like anybody that were was
like like women would be stripped naked
in the middle of a town hall looking for
birthmarks because if they had a
birthmark it was the mark of the double
you know like like a man would get an
erection and say like that woman is
magical and that woman would be burned
at the stakes like it wasn't like just
childbearing women it was children it
was grandmothers it was like lots and
lots of women that nine million nine
million yes this history not known why
is it exactly exactly
um and so it was a dark time in Europe
uh there was lots of famine there was I
mean if the mother figure if the
matriarch is missing of course it's
gonna be dark right and uh at that point
there they were thinking there's not
enough uh like laborers to work so what
they ended up doing is
um women knew their fertility prior to
this it was talked about in those red
tents the average uh you know amount of
women that children had was typically
about three to four children
once that was erased and The Midwives
the herbalists the family physicians
didn't have the you know the education
that they were bringing forth of how to
know their fertility the rates went to
about 12 to 13 child children in in one
family so a mom one mom would have 12 to
13 children which would is then child
labor right that's why child labor laws
and everything got started
and so it there was there was just
injustice all over like there was no
place that wasn't grim and awful
um and you know men would even look at
the menstruation as a streak of the
devil like it was it was definitely a
time where they were trying to I'm like
what point in history was this so it
started at 1484. this is when the book
came out the witch's Hammer
um and so it spread throughout now at
that time we started you know think of
Christopher Columbus right so we started
having that uh the the immigration over
to the United States now I promise you
that Native Americans here knew what
they were doing with birth right like it
was when we started having the like
westerners come over and bringing
syphilis and all this weird and
their Western priest doctors
and as these um rates the population
started growing in the United States
they started to kind of come together
with the church of some sort of like
medicine like you know the practice of
medicine and medical school
um in 1700s uh women were not even
allowed to step foot into medical school
so you know think of that like any time
that you got hurt growing up any time
that you were needing any sort of
healing most people would turn to their
mom or their grandmother or you know
some female figure never a male
typically like it was you go to get
Comfort or comforted by the female
figure so when they completely extracted
the female from medical school in 1700
it really changed medicine to a uh
profit driven controlled type of
medicine and so um you know you look
back at 1972 right that's not that long
ago and 90 of the doctors that were
entering medical school were still male
yeah yeah okay 500 years then since the
Extinction essentially of yeah like the
the medical medical woman yes and so
um during that time there was also the
slaves that were being brought over from
Africa
and there wasn't as much of a forgotten
history about the The Midwives the
herbalists all of that they hadn't
touched they hadn't gone there to
execute all of their witches down there
right so as these slaves came they they
had this storytelling they had the
experience of witnessing their their
Nana's and their aunties be midwives and
so this got brought into the United
States yeah these were called granny
midwives and
um the granny midwives would go and
they'd have really good outcomes you
know birth was like starting to bring
any midwives so these the
African-Americans that have come over or
are these just slaves in general are
like what the African African-American
slaves that were brought over that knew
and had the knowledge of of Midwifery of
you know a female practitioner that yeah
provided practicing they kept practicing
so uh in the 1900s 19 in actually 1900 a
hundred percent of birth in the United
States were at home okay damn 100
percent
um by the time that we got into the
1930s 1940s we were looking about 50 of
bursts that were then moved to the
hospital so they went on these smear
campaigns with these granny midwives and
they would post ads now remember at that
time who owned the media and still does
was the Rockefellers right and they
owned the newspapers and they owned all
these things and so there would be
pictures of these beautiful
African-American women that were the
granny midwives of the South and they
would say that they were dirty and that
they were you know killing moms and
babies and don't associate with these
women and
um so the affluent people uh didn't want
to have any association with these
granny midwives and so they they said
well let's birth at the hospital and so
what ended up happening is these men
would uh go in and think that they
controlled birth right so they would lay
women flat on their back and they would
give them a drug called scopol meme
Scopolamine is an eraser so you're like
anesthetized completely out of your
mind and you have no memory of
it you were you have amnesia like being
like it's like being like drugged in the
club like being drugged it's like being
roofied right yeah and so what would
happen is that these women were tied up
literally tied up to the beds okay and
their feet were put up in forceps
the doctor sat level with the with the
chair at their vagina and they would
control these births now if you can't
really tell a mom that is under
anesthesia directions you can't say push
or do this so they would wait for the
baby to start to come and then they
would go in with forceps and they would
pull these babies out cut the cord right
away whisk the baby away to another area
put them in the nursery right like
that's all the pictures you see back
then as the dad standing smoking their
cigars looking at their babies in the
nursery where the nurses attended to
these babies that was birth that was
birth for a long time I mean I've seen
Scopolamine used in birth in my 20-year
career in a hospital before yes they're
you know the history dates back to women
being on their backs and we know that
squatting is one of the most universal
positions for giving birth squatting
increases the pelvic Outlet by 33
percent
um but but the reason that that these
women were placed on their backs is
because they were drugged
and it was convenient for the doctor to
have them level with third feet up and
forceps
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen